you know it's not like just cuz you love
football or hip-hop or roses that you're
entitled to build a million dollar
business around that passion is
massively important I'll tell you why
work ethic is an absolute pillar of
variable to being successful and if
you're passionate about something it
doesn't feel like work and that's a big
deal like if you feel like if you're
working on your side hustle from 6:00 to
2:00 in the morning 6 p.m. 7 p.m. right
and you're not up for it
like you're forcing yourself because you
need the money or the dream you've
[ __ ] up you picked the wrong thing
like to punt all your leisure and all
your friends and family and to work on
something and to be tired the next day
because you have to get up for work what
you really don't want to do which is why
you're building your side hustle that
has to be about your passion because
it's just too hard if it's not it can't
be about what do you think you can make
the most money what I don't think people
understand is you can make a lot more
like there's a lot so I will crush it a
long time ago the emails that I get I
get way more people that are making 50
to 200 thousand a year talking about the
craziest like the emails I get are so
bananas like love bananas in my snapchat
so I won't use that like like hey Gary
Vee I you know I read crush it in 2009
and I'm making 74 thousand dollars a
year and ads and selling t-shirts around
raspberry jam only I've had a lot more
people make money do you think Pete been
the longest tail leash that you could
have ever thought of hip hop stars from
1986 to 1989 there's a real one
there's a guy who only talks about hip
hop from 86 to 89 because he was in high
school during those years and now he's
like now he gets paid like five to ten
thousand dollars a month retainer to do
hip hop consulting for companies that
came from the content he was putting out
he let me stop being an accountant I
mean right but the people that are
losing are I tried to build an affiliate
marketing company I tried to do $500
ebooks they went for the money they had
no patience the hip-hop guy and the
raspberry jam girl and this guy
I had years of nobody giving a [ __ ]
before we popped I did y1b TV for two
years with not with crickets crickets
we'll kids you going and doing that
because I knew I was right